[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the new york knicks will
sign kemba walker as a free agent
sources tell the athletic let's bring in
frank isola the net studio host on yes
also has a sirius xm uh radio show
the starting lineup and contributor to
around the horn and pardon the
interruption let me start there
the knicks they're they're getting these
these players yes it's the magic of the
playoffs that win against the hawks
frank they got kemba walker
and your reaction is well he as you know
dan he is a new yorker so
and he's an upgrade on what they had so
you put him with derrick rose as your
two point guards it's not terrible you
know the problem with kemba walker we
saw him get exposed a couple of times
or a few times defensively he is
undersized and the big thing with him
will be
can he stay healthy remember last year
the celtics
they weren't playing kemba in back to
backs the idea was to keep him ready and
fresh for the playoffs and then he ended
up missing playoff games
so who knows what his health is at this
point all right let's look at the lakers
step by step move by move here uh when
they
let's start with russell so that
upgrade for you you like the move with
russell westbrook
i i like it during the regular season
how it works in the playoffs i don't
know because
you know he's a ball dominant guard
who's not a great shooter
and you know when you do get to the
playoffs in these you know crucial
moments of games you want the ball in
lebron james's hand so if russell
westbrook going to be playing off the
ball
and if so is he going to be the one
knocking down shots i get it to get
through a regular season
lebron you know doesn't want to play 82
games at this stage of his career he
wants guys to carry him
and it's almost as if he knows now that
anthony davis can't be that guy
i understand why they did it in theory
it's an upgrade i'll be interested to
see how it works during the postseason
yeah i'm with you on that
it feels like russ he never takes a
possession off like every
every possession matters to him and
he'll play hard the entire regular
season
although there are times when i want him
to maybe take a couple of plays off or
not have every possession mean as much
all right
now you get mellow what do you think of
the addition of mel
yeah i mean if you look at carmelo the
last few years i mean he's accepted his
role he's now a
bit player who will play between 20 and
25 minutes a game he could still knock
down mid-range jumpers i get it he and
lebron have been friends since high
school they've always wanted to play
together they played together on the
national team
they've been in all-star teams together
i i think it's i think it's fine
because you're not getting carmelo
you're not asking him to be your
starting power forward
he is getting up there in age but he
proved on portland he could be a
contributing player i think he wants to
make a run at it you've seen that list
there's only eight guys that have won
a national championship a college
championship
and then a gold medal and carmelo wants
to be the ninth guy to do that all right
the other additions here who stands out
more
um well westbrook is obviously uh
a really good one um malik monk kent
basemore
wayne ellington i mean they needed
shooting
so in theory i would say you know wayne
ellington isn't a bad one i think
getting dwight howard back is good you
know dan if you look
last year with mantras harold they got
montres herald on a bargain basement
contract and he did not play well i mean
he really didn't give them a lot
and it's it's interesting if you look at
what happened with giannis antetokounmpo
in the finals
where phoenix really didn't have anybody
after deandre to
deal with him all of a sudden size seems
to matter again
in the nba and dwight howard helped the
lakers when they won a title
and dwight has kind of become in a lot
of ways
morphing into a bit of a dennis rodman
type where
he's constantly out there trying to
agitate the opposition
trying to draw technical fouls he's
really done a good job
developing into that kind of role player
so i think he's going to help them a lot
for the money to me he's an upgrade over
manchester
and and i agree with you on the uh the
rodman dwight howard comparison because
like
knowing your role is really important
when you get on a lebron team
and i also wonder can they do anything
with dennis schroeder with a sign in
trade can the lakers
because i i still it's weird through
free agency i mentioned this
i thought of dame lillard and dennis
schruter schroeder turning down
the extension with the lakers and then
is was he going to be in no man's land
and dame lillard looking around going uh
we got cody zeller
and tony snell uh and ben mclemore we're
not going anywhere but
can the lakers benefit from dennis
schroeder with a signing trade
yeah they could still get something for
him and that's why you love when guys
say bet on yourself well dennis sure to
bet on himself it really hasn't worked
out to this point he should have taken
that 84 million dollar contract that he
was offered you mentioned damien lillard
i would think that this year they'll try
to get through the season
with load and if it doesn't work out
then i can see a trade
you know at the earliest the deadline i
doubt that would happen i could see
something with damien lewd around next
year's
nba draft that's usually when these big
deals tend to happen so if it doesn't
work out for portland
if they're not making steady progress in
the western conference i think that
damian lloyd will be out
by next summer steph curry signed a new
extension
and the last year of that deal i think
he makes close to 60 million dollars
crazy where is this can this is this is
sustainable frank that i i don't know
how it is and you know that a lot of
owners are talking about this and when
the collective barring agreement
whatever it does expire it's got to be
something that will be addressed at
least steph curry in his case now who
knows what he's going to be like
five years from now when the contract
expires because it doesn't even kick in
until next season
but he has been an unbelievable player
two-time all-star he's won finals there
you know he's been
he's revitalized that entire
organization one of the reasons they
really build
that amazing arena that they have but
there's going to come a point where you
look at some of these contracts even
lonzo ball
getting four years 85 million he's a
very good player
all he's done has been on losing teams
and it's you know so you i get it you're
paying for potential with steph you're
paying
for services already rendered but the
money is crazy i think in the nba world
they're calling it dan patrick money oh
is that what
that stuff curry got yeah it's very much
so i think it's bill simmons
money but but but it but 60 million
where you know we we freak out when
patrick mahomes signs his deal and we go
oh my god
they're paying him that much and you're
going like he would be
just another marquee player in the nba
with his salary here yeah i i remember
when eli manning first signed his
contract
with the giants they said it was 100
million but the guaranteed money
was what trevor ariza was making on the
middle level exceptions so eli manning
was basically getting trevor a reason of
money
but dan you know this when you go back
to michael jordan's last two years with
the chicago bulls
michael jordan got 30 million for both
those he was like you know in the 30 to
35 million
range and even back then you're like you
know what he's definitely worth it but
now you think
all these years later steph curry
essentially is going to be making double
that
amazing but it didn't count against the
cap with jordan did it
no no no he was a yeah he remember
that's when the knick fans as you know i
mean we're still
playing this game where the knick fan
was thinking maybe michael jordan
would take the mid-level exception or
minimum to come play in new york
and then jerry reinzor stepped up to the
plate and said i'll give you 30 million
and then i think it was 30 to 33 million
and michael jordan wisely stayed in
chicago won two more championships and
got his money
do you think the knicks feel zion
williamson will be in play for them
in a couple years i i definitely think
they do believe that and when zion
played at madison square garden the last
time around
he recited all the familiar verses about
it's the mecca basketball it's a great
place to play the whole
it was almost as if the knicks gave him
a script and you look at new orleans
you know they got a lot of good young
players they haven't come close to
sniffing the playoffs yet
so and you the western conference is
tough so it could get to a point with
zion
where the pelicans are in the same
position they were in
with anthony davis where you're looking
to get assets traffic at least that's
something that right now
the knicks still have the kawhi leonard
situation with the clippers
where coming off the acl does he even
play this year does he want to play this
year
what do you like the clippers it feels
like they're damned if they do damned if
they don't
what do you think makes the most sense
in this situation from the clippers
perspective
well considering everything that they
gave up to get paul george
all those sec first round picks do they
really have any other option
but to resign kawhi leonard likely not
going to play this season just like a
similar situation with the nets and
kevin durant his first year there where
he didn't play
and then you just keep your fingers
crossed he's going to be able healthy
enough and he'll
you know still come back in top form
what i don't get though dan
is you have kawhi you know it came out
now quite insane it was reports that he
wanted to talk to other teams
talk to other teams about what first of
all not a lot of teams have money
and at some point i know this is like a
bad word in sports
does loyalty ever come into the equation
you wanted them to go out and get paul
george they moved heaven and earth
to get him and now here you are knowing
that you're not even going to play
and you're saying well maybe i'll talk
to other teams i don't know about that
yeah i think there's a lot of things
that go on behind the scenes
with kawhi that if it was somebody else
we would be calling them out
yeah it feels like you know because
kawhi is not media friendly
you don't hear much from him but it
feels like somebody's pulling strings
behind the scenes here whether it's
kawhi
or his uncle like some something's going
on there
and it doesn't seem like he gets a lot
of blame no he doesn't i think maybe
being aloof has something to do with the
fact that you said he's really not that
engaging
with the media even when they lost last
year when they blew the 3-1 lead
to the denver nuggets you're the star
player of the team usually in those
situations if that's lebron wherever he
is if it's patrick ewing who's he was in
new york
you're going to get crushed and it was
like well doc rivers it's really his
fault that we lost or it's this guy's
fault or paul george
nobody really blamed the star of the
team and it's his uncle dennis who uh
who i think is sometimes pulling the
strings who by the way
lives in the same areas uh kyrie irving
so that would be a good little
lunch date get together with uncle
dennis and kyrie talk basketball
how did the nets do in the off season i
think they did really well first of all
they
the three talented players that they
have should be healthy for the start of
the season
but you know patty mills is good yeah
and patty mills was thinking about the
lakers
came to the nets i'm sure the whole sean
marks you know the san antonio spur
mafia
steve nash being an international player
like
like patty mills i'm sure that i'll
factor in that's a great
signing for them go back to the playoffs
joe harris great regular season
but some clutch moments especially in
that game seven could knock down a shot
paddy mills will make
those shots yeah i brought that up it's
one thing to hit a jumper when you're
blowing teams out by 30 in the regular
season and you're you're having a and
one mixtape there
yeah but when it's this possession you
need to hit this shot
and that's why i wonder about the
players the lakers brought in
for the most part these guys malik munt
and kent basemore
wayne ellington you're right they
haven't hit big shots forever
yeah they haven't hit big shots and i
think that'll that'll be
you know the interesting part of this
would you bet on the lakers
playing for a championship this year the
only reason why i think i might
is just because i don't know the
situation with jamal murray
in denver there's you know he had he got
injured april 12th the season is going
to end
right around that time so that's a year
out of having acl surgery
kawhi is not going to play and the big
thing will be and it's true of everybody
health will be a factor if lebron is
healthy anthony davis is healthy
by the start of the playoffs i think the
lakers can get there the nets probably
have a bit of a tougher road with
milwaukee
and miami but i think the nets are the
best team and maybe you'll get a finals
with
the dynamic between kyrie and lebron
russell westbrook and kevin durant and
then in the case of anthony davis
and james harden the two guys that
forced their way out of their teams
pretty nasty divorce so it almost works
perfectly if we get them in nba finals
good to talk to you frank thanks for
seeing you dan take care
that's frank isola net studio host on
yes also has his own show on siriusxm
nba radio the starting lineup and uh
contributor to around the horn
and pardon the interruption